If you're a young person, and you are not so sure what is the perfect career for you,...
...it means that you have not tried enough things.
Because it's like sports,...
...how do you know what sports you would excel in, if you haven't played enough?
So, let's say you've only played basketball your whole life.
You're like, you know what? Maybe I'm a pretty good basketball player,...
...but maybe you're only five foot five.
And you thought, "You know what? This is what I like to do, maybe this is my career."
Well, maybe you haven't tried other things.
Have you tried swimming?
Have you tried football?
Have you tried soccer?
Have you tried ping-pong?
Have you tried other sports?
When you try enough things, it is an elimination process.
Very quickly you would know, you know what, that's not my thing.